okay if you're listening to the podcast
i'm wondering what the heck's going on
here with the format with the lack of
formalities uh we're trying something
new
i'm just asking people uh you know who
are guests on the program if they
consider going on live
when we go live we use a piece of
software called restream it sends a
video stream to youtube facebook twitter
twitch linkedin which is kind of cool
facebook which
i guess we don't get any viewers over
there anymore um
well it's interesting you know turner
when you when you
build up an audience on these platforms
then at some point the platform's like
well just take that audience back and
then charge you for it so facebook i
have like zillions of followers 100 000
people following the page whatever
and like three people get a notification
about the video and they're just like
would you like to promote this i'm like
no i want to reach the original audience
that you convinced me to build for five
years
and whatever do you know what fixes this
what fix is that crypto yeah web3 have
you have you heard of it before have you
looked into it i have um all right
listen let me just give a brief overview
of who turner novak is you can follow
him at turner novak on twitter uh he
gained massive popularity over the past
couple years uh in his uh full
30 months as a vc
uh just
basically turned uh ish posting into a
fund his fund is called banana capital
and uh he's quite spicy on the twitter
turner how did you get into adventure
well it's a very long story but
essentially
it's a podcast so we have time
yeah i mean how much do you want do you
want the 30 second do you want the 30
minutes or somewhere in between yeah
though in between whatever you choose
so you wanted to get into vc but
when you were younger or
when you think of pie
yeah i guess the kind of the full the
minute context originally from canada
moved to the us my parents got divorced
dad moved back to canada mom went back
to school to get a visa stay in the
country
couldn't really work so volunteer under
the table get paid cash gift cards got
food from the food bank growing up she
also had a small business she designs
custom handmade wedding gowns which is a
decent business if you're in new york
paris not the best business if you're in
a small city in the midwest uh and i
just spent time on the internet as a kid
got kicked off the computers at school
every year
that kind of uh
an upbringing and just knew i'd do
something kind of tech related but when
school for accounting and finance joined
the investment club in college and was
like holy crap you buy a stock and it
goes up yeah stop investing yeah they
don't go down they only go up like
investing this is awesome i want to be
an investor and i just kind of went down
that rabbit hole where you know
where you were in college i'm curious
just to pin it to the stock market
yeah 2009 through 2014 i did a victory
lap my last three years i like cut down
i just did a bunch of internships to
make money and avoid student loans and
uh yeah so i would i would look at a
company like uber like it's worth 100
billion dollars publicly traded but why
can i invest in uber when it was worth
like 1 billion or there's some people
that were like the first investors in
uber like
whatever yeah you want to do that third
or fourth like fifth i don't know but
anyway so so you became like at some
point
aware of private companies do you
remember how you became aware of private
companies you was reading like
techcrunch or something
yeah honestly i don't i don't remember
specifically i mean i think it was it
was probably around the facebook ipo the
twitter ipo i'd watch
the
opening bell with my roommates and be
like oh man
like i'm more the twitter ipo it took
like six hours like it didn't go public
until like two in the afternoon we like
skipped class and i just were thinking
like maybe not maybe not twitter
specifically but like facebook what a
great business like why am i why would i
invest in the ipo like why can't i just
invest before like how do i set myself
up to to go earlier and that was a long
process of figuring all that out and
being in probably the third best city in
michigan to get into tech in vc like it
was a it was a long process but yeah
just
essentially i just
got some jobs related to investing and
kind of more financially in michigan
started writing online a lot just picked
some topics to write about that i
thought would
be worth kind of like
planting the flag building a track
record around i did this fantasy vc
portfolio it's like fantasy football but
with startups
and uh initially my twitter was probably
99
serious uh back in the day and now it's
like one percent serious 99 just means
winners for joking trolling i mean you
get a lot more attention from that but
just to confirm
instead of going to class you decided to
cut class and instead of trying
deciding to cut class to go hang out
with chicks or to go drink beer or to go
to the quad and smoke weed
your you and your dork friends went to
watch cnbc
and watch the twitter ipo
i i would like to think i was a lot
cooler than that but yeah essentially
the ultimate nerd move it's pretty great
actually i
uh so
you're writing online you get a little
bit of attention but then you want to
start your own fund
and how old are you at this time that
you decide you're going to start your
own fund because that's the kind of new
thing that's occurred here is that yeah
uh young people actually believe they
can start their own funds and they
actually succeed which just didn't even
seem like a possibility i'll be honest
and you're just it's stupid i don't know
why you're even trying it to be honest
uh yeah it was kind of an accident i
mean i
had been essentially trying to prove i
could be a vc from michigan which
essentially meant being online instead
of in san francisco and this was
like early 2019 was when i finally got
all the interviews and everyone was like
you got to move to san francisco you
can't be a vc unless you're here no
which made sense at the time but my you
know when i think about like my
advantage like if you're a startup you
got to think how do you attack the
incumbents i was like how do i
compete against the incumbent vcs or
just like the people who are
you know probably like a shoe-in to get
the jobs you know i'm the complete
opposite kind of
background and network that i have set
up so i was just like i don't think i
need to be in san francisco so yeah i
that's
kind of i just tried to figure out how
to make it work and i took an internship
it's like a pretty big pay cut um and i
actually had to sell my hopes because i
couldn't afford my mortgage and then we
had a rental property that
you can buy rent you can buy real estate
in michigan for like sixty five thousand
dollars so i sold it because yeah i had
a ton of equity in it and we had to move
so we just moved right next to my
in-laws instead of in in ann arbor on
the other side of the state instead of
moving to san francisco and then
pandemic hit um as i was i joined this
uh real estate firm called gelt and they
were like hey let's raise the venture
fund for our real estate lps and with
the pandemic covey they were really
focused on the real estate business it
was it was tough to get lp's to come in
and i just had a bunch of people that
were like turner you know we've been
co-investing together like if you ever
start your own funds like
i'm in like i had a bunch of money kind
of soft committed for this fund that i
actually wasn't going out to try to do
but
i just hit a point where everyone was
like yo you got it you got to do this
like i think you'd be good and i thought
you know maybe in 20 years i'd launch my
own firm i think that's why i told my
pay your yeah
yeah like that's what i told my wife the
first date that we had you know i was
like what do you want to do is like i
want to be an investor i want to run my
own firm one day and i was like 23 at
the time
yeah i think i'm 30 right now
started raising this right before i
turned 30 in in january was officially
when i was like okay i
have to do something and i just kind of
went back to all the people that i've
been talking to meeting co-investing
with all the founders i'd backed and
told people what was happening and
everybody wanted to invest so and it was
my thesis was i can use memes to get
distribution online and it's way more
efficient than anything else and it was
while gamestop was happening and that
was not a tough sell at the time like
everyone's like oh memes duh like this
makes sense right so
just really lucky timing with how covet
the pandemic happened how meets have
kind of blown up it just all kind of
worked in my favor so yeah super lucky
if you don't have business insurance you
failed one of the first steps of being a
great founder startups should look no
further than in broker
broker's technology saves you time and
money prices are like up to 20 lower and
they got better coverage than all these
slow incomes you can go from sign up to
quote and purchase in just 10 minutes i
kid you not and when you work with in
broker instead of business insurance
incumbents you're not dealing with large
slow corporations the sign up takes days
not weeks and the process is so
transparent there's no opaque pricing
there's no negotiation you just get it
all done easy peasy lemon squeezy i'm
going to quickly explain to you one
crucial type of start of insurance that
embroker covers it's called eo you may
have heard it or overheard it it covers
errors and omissions that'll help you
deal with scaling your business and
because any major customer you try to
sign up is going to say hey can you show
us your eno part of the diligence
process if you want to get it now it's
not that expensive these things are part
of the process of growing up as a
startup and you know what i find
sometimes people wait until they get
burned to put on their insurance the
insurance is not that expensive you want
to do it proactively especially if
you've raised money recently that's the
perfect time to deploy a little bit of
capital into protecting the kingdom
protect your enterprise so to instantly
buy custom built insurance for startups
go to inbroker.com twist and while
you're there you get 10 off they're
already amazing prices by using the
offer code list twist in broker
e-m-b-r-o-k-e-r dot com slash twist all
right thanks for supporting the show on
broker love you guys